il y a des tas de gens qui disent moi je
ferais bien la grève mais c'est embêtant
parce qu'il faut que j'aille au boulot
alors les deux années d'études qu'est-ce
que vous faites pendant la première mais
pendant la première forcément ce sont
des cours théoriques naturellement vous
avez apprentissage et confection de la
banderole confection de pancartes
j'avais aussi apprentissage de slogan la
deuxième année c'est carrément la
pratique alors vous avez formation de
cortège déformation de cortège vous avez
des stages des stages dans les
formations politiques de gauche et de
droite n'est-ce pas et vous avez
lancement du pavé
sur vous avez vous avez j'imagine que
vous avez également protection contre la
matraque et à ce que vous avez
utilisation du couvercle de poubelle
surtout je suppose que le port du le
port du casque est obligatoire il est
obligatoire pour les jeunes gens qui
pour les parents qui voudraient que
leurs enfants deviennent manifestants
professionnels c'est au départ pendant
tous des exercices pratiques c'est pas
dangereux dangereux pas du